if you're having problems paying your
utility bills NV Energy the sponsors of
this next segment are here to help
joining us now to talk about their Flex
Pay is Antoine Tillman the vice
president of customer operations welcome
back to the show hey there how are you
doing it's always great to chat with you
FlexPay tell me more about it so FlexPay
is a program it's a prepaid program
customers actually pay when when they
want to so you'll basically kind of like
a a gas card right you you have your
vehicle you keep gas in it if it gets
low you fill it up so Flex Pay similar
It's a prepaid program for CV energy
your paying as the month goes on versus
the traditional at the end of the month
you get your utility bill correct
correct so what you're doing is you're
actually seeing what you're using on a
daily basis and then you're keeping that
based on your consumption you can keep
your gas tank full okay someone's
watching right now how do they qualify
this how do they sign up for this so
everybody's qualified and your meter is
the only thing so if we have a meter
that we can remotely disconnect or
connect that qualifies you for that
program there are some other other
exceptions to that what if you go to our
website it'll show you what what those
are are you is there a credit check
involved or anyone just can jump on
there and sign up no the best thing
there is no credit check matter of fact
if you have a deposit you can actually
have that deposit reverse and apply to
your account while you set up on Flex
Pay is there a deposit initial deposit
to start up your Flex Pay someone's
going to sign up do they have to put
fifty dollars like putting fifty dollars
in a tank to fill your car up for the
first time so there is that that initial
payment that you'll do and that'll go to
towards your gas tank okay it's not like
a deposit fee that's going to your
actual bill right it's going right into
your gas tank so it's not a deposit that
we're holding just in case it's actually
going towards your your um account oh I
like this you put 50 bucks in and then
your business is there a minimum to
start or whatever you can afford you
start off with there's no minimum to
start the fifty dollars is the minimum
okay start that but once you once you go
from there there's no minimum depending
on how you pay there are minimums amount
that you can pay but from different
areas you can actually pay as if you
only need two dollars you could put two
dollars on there this is great yes you
guys always give back to Las Vegas and
you're looking out for your customers
and that's what I love about NV Energy
you really do you care about this
community yes yes and this program is
really designed if you fall behind on
your account the best thing about this
account is when you make a payment let's
say you you pay a dollar yep um and you
owe us some money 20 of I'm sorry 20
cents of that dollar goes towards your
rares and and then the other 80 goes
into your gas tank so this is great and
it happens automatically so you just
relax just keep the gas tank full and
everything else to take care of itself I
gotta wrap it up real quick someone's
going leaving for the holidays leaving
town for like a week what should they
leave their thermostat at when it comes
to their heater so again if your your
comfort zone is about 68 to 70 is what
we recommend during the winter time so
dropping that down to about 64 is a safe
bet you could drop it down later
depending on the envelope of your home
perfect awesome thank you so much
Antoine we appreciate it and thank you
to Envy energy for sponsoring this
segment for more information visit
nbenergy.com forward slash Flex Pay
we'll be right back